[Musique]
bonjour
je suis joueur du Grenier et je ne sais
pas lire c'est pour ça que j'utilise
audible depuis des années audible c'est
un catalogue de 600000 titres audio à
télécharger sur votre smartphone
tablette ordinateur ou Amazon echo
audible dispose du plus grand catalogue
audio qui existe c'est le Netflix du
livre polar roman science-fiction ou
développement personnel il y en a pour
tous les goûts j'écoute actuellement le
manuel de mon autocuiseur en néerlandais
pour me détendre
en plus tous les titres que vous
téléchargez vous appartiennent à vie
même quand vous résiliez l'abonnement
avec l'application audible vous emportez
votre bibliothèque partout avec vous et
retrouvez ainsi toutes vos histoires et
vos auteurs préférés pour un vrai moment
de culture de détente et de plaisir et
ce même hors connexion après les
avancées
enfin je n'ai plus besoin de toi Bobby
tu es libre prends cette chaussette
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à essayer le service avec
mon lien
audible.fr/jdg qui vous donne deux mots
gratuits et surtout n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
c'est toujours pas lire
les chaises enfants de la nuit bienvenue
et préparez-vous pour
et on applaudit notre recadrer officiel
pour ce soir fête du bruit pour
te tuer
[Musique]
c'est un fait ce soir amuse-toi un peu
là
c'est du Bernard
je vous présente c'est à Lucas c'est mon
fils à moi il est très beau très fort
très viril
salut les filles je m'appelle alucarde
ça veut dire Dracula à l'envers c'est
original
et vous vous êtes quoi comme monstre
pardon je dis vous êtes quoi comme
monstre ah moi je suis vice-président du
groupe Nestlé
[Musique]
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle je suis au
regret de vous apprendre que les Balkany
ne pourront pas venir
[Musique]
ce qui est con c'est que si je fais
pareil avec mon gosse on vient au point
de départ et ça fait un genre de boucle
une boucle de pas d'imagination
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les vampires bon alors vous savez tout
ce que c'est qu'un vampire vous savez
tout ce que ça a été inspiré de vrais
gens comme Vlad dépêche dit l'Empaleur
souverain cruel de Transylvanie qui
ensuite inspira la légende de Dracula
repris dans un roman de Bram Stocker en
1897 et quand je vous dis Dracula
évidemment vous avez tous l'image de ce
monsieur grand avec des canines à serrés
Jeff Bezos un look qui d'ailleurs lui
aura été donné par le film Dracula de
1931 même si derrière on aura d'autres
films plus populaires comme le Dracula
de Coppola de 1992 et tout un tas
d'autres œuvres qui mettent en scène des
vampires Twilight Buffy contre les
vampires Vampires Diaries hôtel
Transylvanie ou même des super-héros
comme Blade ou Morbius concernant les
jeux vidéo les vampires ça fait partie
de ces trucs bien pratiques tout le
monde connaît on sait qu'ils vivent la
nuit qui se transforme en chauve-souris
qu'ils aiment pas l'ail qui boivent du
sang bref il y a pas besoin de les
présenter et ça les développeurs ils
aiment bien commençons donc par le jeu
le plus connu avec des vampires je parle
évidemment de Bram Stocker masculin
sorti sur tout un tas de supports et ici
on va tester la version Mega CD le jeu
s'ouvre donc sur des extraits du film
parce que après tout merci le CD
[Musique]
mais seulement 12 pixels mais hier
c'était le double
ça donne pas du tout envie d'éteindre
instantanément à la console les oiseaux
veulent pas il va pleuvoir dans ce jeu
on va donc jouer Jonathan Harker
interprété par Keanu Reeves qui comme
dans les films arrivent au manoir de
Dracula pour lui faire signer des
papiers
alors normalement dans le film il est
assistant du notaire
du coup il y a vraiment un côté badass
dans ce que je suis en train de voir là
je vais te lancer avec des millions
d'ennemis insupportables qui te sautent
dessus en permanence et ça aurait pu
être un jeu chiant classique mais non il
fallait que en plus d'être chiant ça se
traîne mais il y a des Roumains qui se
servent de ta gueule pour faire du
lancer de hache et des chauves-souris
qui font la taille de ma boulangère ça
te dirait pas de genre trop dîner
et regarder la longueur de Monceau là
comment vous voulez j'évite ses pièges
là qu'est-ce que c'est que cette c'est
pour capturer quoi en plus la
détriceratops ouais faut finir le niveau
1 pour rejoindre ton uber qui était
soi-disant garé juste à côté et on entre
dans le château de Dracula oh
je regrette pas du tout les 500 balles
dépensés juste pour ce moment là
en fait si je regarde par contre animé
les portes c'était trop compliqué on
dirait
oui bon alors je vais pas vous infliger
ça en entier à moi non plus d'ailleurs
ce jeu n'a absolument aucun intérêt
c'est juste des niveaux pourris avec des
ennemis pourris que tu enchaînes pour
voir une cinématique pourrie ok attends
scène qui fait peur
oh [ __ ] quoi c'est c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est on a aussi eu une
version Super NES ou vous combattez avec
l'arme la plus petite du monde j'ai tout
à fait banal avec une notion
particulièrement bizarre de ce qui peut
être une plateforme genre cet objet sur
le mur
aucun [ __ ] de sens et est-ce qu'ils
ont oublié d'inverser ce sprite là
pourquoi la moitié des ennemis regarde
dans la mauvaise direction par rapport
au sens où j'arrive et pourquoi le jeu
me faire commencer dans un ennemi quand
je meurs pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas
avoir un seul [ __ ] de jeu avec Dracula
un minimum travaillé bon alors ok vous
sortez d'une télé mais genre si je mets
le film sur un rétroprojecteur vous
sentez plutôt de la lentille ou de la
toile et si vous sortez virer trop
projecteur vous êtes à l'envers mais
vous êtes toute petite comme ça parce
que si vous vous adaptez à la taille de
l'écran et il faut passer le film au
Grand Rex
attends tu as une protection
[Musique]
aucune raison particulière
OK
je crois que j'ai entendu quelque chose
mais je suis pas sûr peut-être que je
vais mourir mettez des likes au cas où
[Musique]
c'est rien c'était un chat
c'était le même chat
oh mon dieu
j'ai marché dans de la litière pour chat
c'est vraiment bizarre comme forêt
[Musique]
derrière
yeah ouais c'est vrai on me le dit
souvent j'ai un joli derrière derrière
toi il y a un tueur derrière toi oui
c'est mon dernier clip vous voulez que
je vous le chante
attention il y a un tueur derrière toi
et ce tueur
oh c'est trop gentil
[Musique]
il toi qu'elle est ouais c'est pas ma
préférée celle-là bonjour
[Musique]
mais quand je parle de jeux Dracula
c'est évidemment pas à ça que vous
pensez évidemment vous ce que vous
voulez voir c'est qui Dracula un jeu de
plateforme tout mignon sorti sur Famicom
regardez voilà la Gy joue je suis sur le
premier boss bon c'est plutôt jouable
plutôt agréable à prendre en main bon
alors après vous le voyez à l'écran il y
a des problèmes le boss clignote un peu
mais bon en même temps ça ça arrivait
régulièrement sur les jeux de la famille
comme non mais attends tu vas pas parler
de ça je suis désolé mais c'est ridicule
les les fantômes ils n'ont pas de pied
mais c'est vrai mais pour un jeu des
années 80 moi j'ai quand même envie de
dire beau boulot les gars mais allez
arrêtons de traîner autour du pot il est
impossible d'évoquer Dracula en jeu
vidéo sans parler de la licence
principale Castlevania sorti en 1986 sur
NES un des jeux fondateurs du jeu vidéo
au même titre que Sonic Mario ou Tomb
Raider dans cette série de jeux on y
incarnera des membres de la famille
Belmont de gigantesques psychopathe qui
débarque tous les 100 ans chez Dracula
pour buter tout le monde péter les murs
vider la cuisine et raser le château
alors évidemment quand on voit ce jeu
maintenant difficile de comprendre en
quoi c'était une révolution mais en 86
des éléments de jeu qui nous semblent
évidents pour nous maintenant ne le sont
pas forcément Castlevania quand ils sort
c'est un bijou de level design déjà tu
arrives devant le château tu commences
dans le jardin il y a pas d'ennemis tu
vois des vases que tu tapes dedans ça
lâche des cœurs et des upgrades ok les
bougies HDM bien compris puis tu entres
dans le château il y a trois zombies qui
te font deux suit ils sont faciles à
tuer avec le fouet ça te permet
d'appréhender les sauts ok j'ai compris
comment tuer les ennemis et esquiver
message reçu et ce que je suis en train
de dire peut sembler idiot mais ça fait
partie de métier extrêmement important
du jeu vidéo qui s'appelle le game
design ou comment faire comprendre
quelque chose aux joueurs sans lui
afficher un gros message du genre les
bougies lâche des items oh oh et c'est
aussi grâce à une courbe de difficulté
très progressive que le jeu se démarque
absolument tout le monde peut faire le
premier niveau de Castlevania et ça
c'est bien surtout à une époque où les
jeunesses avaient tendance à commencer
comme ça
[Musique]
dans le Castlevania chaque rencontre
avec un nouvel ennemi te demande de
réfléchir à comment l'approcher quelle
arme utilisée bref avec une maniabilité
qui même aujourd'hui marche bien et le
tout porté par une musique qui est juste
excellente Castlevania premier du nom
c'est un jeu sur lequel même en 2022 un
enfant peut encore s'amuser c'est de la
merde je déteste les enfants un an après
le premier jeu sort la suite Castlevania
2 Simons Quest les gars vous ne pouvez
pas vous faut juste refaire pareil
refaite pareil on y incarnera Simon
Belmont comme dans le premier jeu et le
jeu est donc la suite directe du premier
vous avez vaincu Dracula vous l'avez tué
et démembré mais vous décidez quand même
de revenir pour réassembler son corps et
le ressusciter afin de le retirer bordel
mais qui fait ça la nawakowski avec
matrix 4
c'est pas faux le jeu commence et ce
coup-ci pas de cinématique pas de
monstre à tuer en avançant tout droit
direct dans l'action sur une musique
épique non ça sera un village et des
textes qui mettent en temps à s'afficher
dès bah après on va dire que c'est pas
moins bien c'est juste différent un peu
comme toi Titouan tu n'es pas
horriblement les tu es juste différent
merci c'est bien allez mange et ce jeu
commence par tout ce que les joueurs
adorent c'est à dire tuer des monstres
en boucle pour ramasser de l'argent
voilà donc prenons tout de suite la
barre de nos attentes et descendons là
jusque là et pour ça il va falloir
Farmer des cœurs parce que dans
Castlevania 2 les coeurs représentent
l'argent contrairement à Castlevania 1
ou les cœurs n'étaient pas de la vie
mais étaient vos munitions alors que
l'argent lui représentait les points et
que le poulet représentait la vie et
vraiment on dirait que faire chier le
joueur c'était un des objectifs du jeu
par exemple le jeu est truffé de blocs
invisible qui te feront passer à travers
le décor il m'a donc falloir jeter de
l'eau bénite sur chaque bloc du jeu pour
les tester afin de savoir si tu peux
marcher dessus chaque [ __ ] de bloc
quelle idée de merde à la fin de chaque
château vous arriverez ensuite devant
une de ces orbe bleue devant lequel
comme moi vous allez sûrement rester
comme un con à taper dans le vide vu
qu'aucun bouton ne permet de les
ramasser avant de réaliser qu'il fallait
acheter un pieux
plutôt dans le niveau pour casser la
boule
[Musique]
il y a un truc trop bizarre dans ce jeu
où tu utilises tout le temps des objets
connus de l'univers des vampires mais de
la mauvaise façon genre je veux dire les
pieux ça sert à tuer les vampires ça
sert pas à casser des boules ou plus
tard dans le jeu où tu dois utiliser un
high non pas pour je sais pas repousser
un vampire mais pour attirer un vendeur
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette logique
c'est complètement con et justement une
des critiques les plus communes sur ce
Castlevania 2 c'est que c'est un jeu du
type mais [ __ ] je dois aller où par
exemple typiquement voilà ce moment où
tu arrives devant un grand lac alors bon
il y a rien à faire je peux juste pas
sauter par dessus parce qu'évidemment
bah sinon ben je meurs dans l'eau et la
solution est en fait de sélectionner
l'orbe bleue dans ton inventaire de se
baisser pendant 10 secondes pour que
magiquement la caméra se baisse et que
tu puisses traverser l'eau
ou aussi bien sûr c'est autre moment
très connu où tu arrives à une impasse
et pour continuer à cet endroit tu dois
sélectionner l'orbe rouge te coller le
nez face à un mur en étant accroupi et
attendre qu'une tornade Vienne
magiquement emmener
40 qui arrive
alors certes les villageois sont censés
te donner des indices mais le jeu a été
traduit avec le cul devant l'église pour
regagner de la vie le laurier ça donne
du goût à la soupe reçoit un sac en soi
du canard du cimetière pour vivre plus
longtemps à l'émotion on va vous ramener
un vrai je pense que c'est juste les
gens dans ce monde ils se fout de notre
gueule
et en plus on peut même pas se fier au
peu qu'on arrive à déchiffrer puisque
les développeurs ont mis des faux
indices dans le tas pour rendre le jeu
plus dur faux indices oh non ma soupe et
pour vous donner une idée dans le cas
précis de la tornade voilà l'indice dans
la version traduite en anglais frappe la
falaise avec la tête pour faire un trou
ok je suppose que vous voulez dire à
genouilles toi devant la falaise avec
une orbe rouge oui c'est ça prends la
poule oui vous voulez dire ouvre la
porte oui je crois qu'on va prendre un
magazine pour la soluce et jouer avec la
soluce bah c'est nul mais c'est juste
obligatoire pour pas rester bloqué
pendant des heures en fait vous vous
souvenez de l'eau bénite que je devais
jeter par terre pour voir s'il y avait
pas un bloc piégé des fois dans les
villages tu vas tomber sur des pièces
vides comme ça bon alors je marche
dessus tout se passe bien je peux
essayer de taper les murs il se passe
rien et du coup bah tu te dis que c'est
juste une pièce vide changement de règle
et ben non en réalité l'eau bénite dont
la seule fonction depuis le début du jeu
était de vérifier les blocs piégés sers
maintenant subitement et sans aucune
explication a casser les murs parce que
le vendeur d'ail bah il est enfermé dans
les murs d'une des maisons en fait le
plus surprenant je crois c'est que une
banque me prêter de l'argent pour ouvrir
tout ça ok c'est de la merde en
barquette mais c'est pas la première
fois j'en ai mangé des kilos déjà je
peux résister faut juste que ça aille
pas plus loin que
allez attention accrochez-vous c'est
l'heure du boss
époustouflant bon allez filez-moi la
mauvaise fin que je puisse me barrer
maintenant mais maintenant
la paix et la
[Musique]
on
page et c'est à pitié
bon après je fais pas trop en rajouter
il y a quand même eu des bonnes idées le
cycle jour nuit qui rend les ennemis
plus forts à intervalle régulier le côté
plus aventure entre guillemets avec les
prémices de RPG avec les items et
l'argent mais bah c'est mal exécuté et
on le sait l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions et de Love
surtout de lave et au final un
paradoxalement le farming les
allers-retours incessants tout ce que je
reproche à ce jeu c'est aussi tout ce
qui fera le succès d'un autre jeu
Castlevania bien plus tard Symphony of
the night sur Playstation 1 qui a
complètement renouvelé la licence
Castlevania et créer le genre du métro
il va venir
les gars
les gars sérieux on devrait pas aller si
loin dans le château
les gars
on sait pas c'est peut-être dangereux
on est des vampires
de vampire
[Musique]
quand même le nombre de célébrités que
Dracula pu rencontrer dans sa vie les
gars il y a pas un truc bizarre il est
où les stats
regarde
en plus il nous indique la direction
pour la suite de la visite
je sais pas c'est vraiment bizarre quand
même
[Musique]
on devrait vraiment pas être là les gars
ils vont se demander où on est
vraiment une poule mouillée
je suis une poule mouillée je vois des
assassins partout
c'est pas ça mais je veux juste dire que
c'est peut-être vraiment interdit d'être
là
[Musique]
et puis je sais pas il y a vraiment un
truc qui me dérange je sais pas trop ce
que c'est
j'ai l'impression
qu'on est pas tout à fait seul oh merde
oh [ __ ] oh merde
[ __ ] mec dépêche-toi
il va me tuer [ __ ] il va me tuer je
veux pas mourir j'ai pas envie de
travailler ici
merci pour les mille-puits
ça marchera pas sur moi je suis juif
[Musique]
alors juste pour dissiper un malentendu
je tue uniquement parce que c'est un
vampire juste parce que c'est un
personnage rien à voir avec enfin voilà
Castlevania 64 attendez une minute on en
a déjà parlé non on va prendre
Castlevania 64 alors il y a des gens qui
aiment mais moi sincèrement j'ai pas
aimé du tout effectivement on en avait
déjà parlé mais comme beaucoup de jeux
dans cette période de JDG on avait dû
jouer à peine une heure dessus se dire
ah [ __ ] la flemme puis laissez tomber
donc il est temps de remettre les doigts
dedans
bref le premier niveau commence dans une
tristesse auditive absolue et ça je
l'avais déjà dit à l'époque le jeu a en
fait fait le choix de ne pas mettre du
tout de musique pour ce niveau 1 à part
pour les boss donc l'ambiance de ce
début de jeu vous offrira un son de
chaussons qui patoche dans la boue
service sur son lit de bruit de terrain
vague le tout pendant que tu tournes en
rond à ne pas savoir où aller grâce à
une bile combinaison de décors qui se
répètent plus que le scénario des
épisodes de Code Lyoko et du fameux
brouillard breton de la Nintendo 64
qu'on a déjà pu apprécier dans moult aux
autres jeux
le seul indice que j'ai trouvé là pour
me repérer c'est un panneau à côté d'un
chemin sur lequel il y a marqué chemin
ce qui techniquement n'est pas faux mais
ça m'aide pas beaucoup quoi mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe là maintenant
pourquoi il y a des squelettes qui font
de la moto dans un [ __ ] de jeu
Castlevania effectivement c'est
n'importe quoi le premier cyclomoteur à
combustion interne alimentée au pétrole
a été inventé par gotlip Da Miller et
William Mayback en 1885 or le jeu se
déroule en 1852 dis tu t'es connais
vachement bien moto en quoi après être
rentré dans la muraille du château on y
croise Dracula une première fois et on
ressort assez vite pour arriver dans le
jardin où
[Musique]
après le jingle de Qui veut gagner des
Millions on affronte deux mini boss bon
et la caméra c'est de la merde la moitié
du temps pendant les combats on dirait
que tu essayes de fouetter l'équipe
technique mais ça je le relève même plus
à force c'est devenu un truc par défaut
sur les jeux de la 64 et on arrive
ensuite jusqu'à Vincent un chasseur de
vampire qui chasse Dracula alors où est
Dracula est-ce qu'il est non cette pièce
de ce côté vers le mur
oh c'est sûr il est pas dans cette pièce
Vincent vous dit donc d'aller parler à
une jeune femme dans le jardin des roses
pièce qu'on a croisé un petit peu plus
tôt donc et c'est ici que le jeu
commence à sentir le vieux P
non celui-là c'était moi
dans cette salle des roses nous devons
donc parler à un PNJ qui n'apparaît qu'à
l'homme et justement ça tombe bien juste
à côté de la salle des roses il y a un
vendeur qui vend un objet qui permet
d'avancer le temps jusqu'au le lever du
soleil c'est à dire 6 heures parce que
oui en gros je passe dessus mais il y a
une dimension de temps qui passe dans ce
jeu ce qui est plutôt cool donc tu
utilises l'item pour avancer le temps et
rien du tout alors bon tu te dis que
peut-être il faut recharger la salle
j'ai déjà vu ça dans d'autres jeux donc
tu sors de la salle puis tu reviens on
sait jamais
toujours rien donc tu te dis que
peut-être il faut utiliser l'item mais
en étant en dehors de la pierre que
dalle et ben super donc on va juste
attendre jusqu'à 6h du matin in game
sans utiliser l'item ce qui prend 15
minutes réel à se toucher la [ __ ]
et toujours pas je suppose que je vais
juste aller me faire [ __ ] dans ce cas
là on fait ça et bien en fait il y a
peut-être petit coquin de développeurs
qui nous a fait une petite farce pour
cette énigme parce que l'homme dans ce
jeu ce n'est pas à 6h mais à 5h donc cet
item vendu exprès pour cette situation
précise à côté de l'endroit où tu en as
besoin de téléporte précisément au
moment du temps où tu es le plus éloigné
de l'instant où le psy apparaît
qu'est-ce qu'on se meurt hein connard
donc Rosa oui elle s'appelle Rosa parce
qu'elle aime les roses nous renvoie vers
Vincent qui vous donne à son tour la clé
décale ce qui en japonais mal traduit
veut dire la clé du Dédale donc je
suppose la clé du labyrinthe alors je
suis pas sûr mais je pense qu'il y a une
perte de qualité dans ce jeu au niveau
des traductions la pièce dorée est-elle
en place
je dirais que la réponse est 7 et non la
réponse était bleue et il a des poèmes
chelous Dracula je trouve le rouge et la
couleur de mars 4
[Musique]
et heureusement que les contrôles de ce
jeu sont bien sinon ça serait vraiment
chiant
bref après avoir rencontré Rosa on
rencontre malus un enfant qui vit seul
ici qui se tape des bouffées de rire
démoniaque en nous disant qu'on va
crever comme des Misérables totalement
pas méchant bien sûr d'ailleurs notre
personnage de calcul rien évidemment
vous allez manger
puis on arrive à un niveau dans une
usine
génial j'adore en plus c'est vraiment
super logique dans l'histoire c'est fou
ils avaient tellement pas envie de faire
un jeu vidéo qui se passe à cette époque
là je veux dire entre les motos d'un
côté les machines la nitro après ils
sont malins par exemple ce n'est pas de
la nitro c'est de la nitro magique
qu'on active en la combinant avec un
minuteur de la mandragore
je rappelle est une plante
j'ai réglé la carotte sur 5 minutes
écartez-vous de la dynamique quant aux
ascenseurs eux ils fonctionnent grâce au
pouvoir magique vous voulez dire
l'électricité non pas du tout c'est le
pouvoir magique
[ __ ] drague on nous a coupé la magie
merde mais qui c'est qui a pas payé la
dernière facture magique parce que moi
j'ai un faux fake casse magique tout
compris bref donc on monte l'ascenseur
et c'est fini
comment ça c'est fini oui je viens juste
de passer maintenant l'histoire est pas
terminée sans aucun sens non on a même
pas tué Dracula effectivement mais tu
t'amuses non je suis toujours ravi de
voir que au bout de 13 ans de vidéos
comme ça on continue à découvrir des
trucs de ce genre et en fait quand tu
joues en mode facile le jeu s'arrête au
milieu de nulle part voilà donc tu
passes une porte d'ascenseur et fin
voilà le jeu te dit que si tu veux voir
la fin bah faut jouer en mode normal
ça s'appelle le mode Facile pas le mot à
moitié vous vous imaginez si les
épisodes
[Musique]
sachez qu'on a vraiment envisagé de
finir l'épisode comme ça donc l'aventure
s'arrête ici pour les gens qui ont joué
en mode facile mais pour les autres on
continue le jeu et on affronte
finalement Rosa c'est celle qui aime les
roses on refuse d'achever après notre
victoire je ne tue que ce que je ne peux
pas baiser la fin du jour ressemble
davantage à un couloir de Beauce et de
scénario entrecoupé de quelques phases
de plateformes horribles on affronte
d'abord la mort dans un combat plutôt
sympa dans lequel Rosa se sacrifie pour
nous sauver et vient fondre dans nos
bras au sens premier elles font puis
ensuite on a droit à une dernière phase
de grimpette qui est un [ __ ] de
cauchemars avec une caméra complètement
en roue libre qui vous fait des Flipendo
gratuit en permanence et on affronte
ensuite les deux derniers boss Vincent
qui entre-temps s'est transformé en
vampire et meurt comme un con en se
jetant lui-même de l'eau bénite sur la
gueule oh merde je me suis coupé le
bouteille
et enfin Dracula qu'on achève après un
combat tellement random et générique que
j'ai déjà oublié de quoi je parlais et
félicitations tu vois la mauvaise fin
quoi et bien en fait d'après ce magazine
si tu fais le jeu trop lentement la
cinématique de fin se termine sur
Reinhardt qui part avec malus et juste
avant le générique son œil devient rouge
révélation plat twist malus était en
fait un méchant comme le montre de
subtiles indices disséminés dans le jeu
visage choqué du coup quand tu traces le
jeu et bien tu as droit à un autre boss
après Dracula le véritable boss de fin
malus non génocidax un méchant et après
avoir vaincu Dracula sous sa vraie forme
celle d'un immense dragon le château
s'effondre et félicitations le jeu est
fini
[Musique]
c'est pas comme si on l'avait
littéralement vu ce dissoudre 30 minutes
avant allez allez-y est-ce qu'il y a
plus de règles dans le scénario allez
ramener qui vous voulez on y est
Robin Williams vous êtes vivant
[Musique]
et un Hidalgo aussi vous êtes vivant
mais attendez une seconde mais je ne
suis pas morte
c'est parce que ça veut dire 64 marquera
le début des jeux Castlevania en pure 3D
d'abord on va dire que c'était plutôt un
faux départ à partir de ce jeu là les
épisodes sur console de salon resteront
tous en 3D avec de très bons opus comme
les Lord of Shadow tandis que les
épisodes sur console portable ce
qu'entendront plus à la recette
traditionnelle Metroidvania façon
symphonie of the night même si la hype a
légèrement resurgi avec l'excellente
série Netflix Castlevania c'est
globalement quelque chose d'assez oublié
de nos jours surtout depuis que Konami
est devenu anecdotique dans le monde des
jeux vidéo et se contente de repointer
leur nez de temps en temps pour vendre
des NFC
alors que c'est ces connards qui ont la
licence suicodon rendez la licence
sudodone rendez-la et pourtant la
licence Castlevania c'est un [ __ ] de
monument c'est un jeu de base c'est des
briques de la maison c'est les
fondations ce sont des jeux qui a posé
quelques-uns des éléments fondateurs de
game design que aujourd'hui encore on
utilise dans tous nos jeux et ça sans
même savoir que ça vient de là
non mais franchement ils auraient pu
faire par continent c'est quand même
plus simple en tout cas c'est très cool
de discuter avec toi
j'arriverai jamais à me faire des potes
merde il paraît très votre ami Monsieur
oh bordel j'ai besoin
[Musique]
tu veux boire un coup quelque chose je
vais aller chercher des bières allez on
revient la merde
moi je vais parfaitement bien
[Musique]
mais je sais pas vrai
ils sont morts ils sont tous morts oui
enfin techniquement on est tous non
c'est hublé n'empêche que quelqu'un tu
es tout le monde
presque tout le monde
père
[Musique]
mon fils mais quand tu fais et oui papa
j'avais tout prévu j'ai d'abord demandé
à Monsieur Gomez de l'entreprise Gomez
et fils d'utiliser un isolant de
mauvaise qualité pendant la rénovation
du château afin de laisser passer
davantage les ondes sonores
n'est-ce pas monsieur Gomez
ensuite tous les matins j'imitais le coq
pour réveiller ce cher Belmont afin de
progressivement lui faire manquer de
sommeil et enfin l'ultime pièce du
puzzle j'ai mis la musique légèrement
trop forte juste au-delà de la limite
des
135,3 dB pour énerver monsieur Belmont
ici présent et l'inciter à venir
massacrer tout le monde ici
pourquoi et moi je sais plus honnêtement
j'ai oublié
et maintenant papa je vais te laisser
mourir afin que s'accomplisse la
prophétie des belles monts et afin du
règne des vampires toi le dernier
vampire encore vivant
enfin avec moi
oh merde
excusez-moi désolé de vous arranger mais
vous pourriez baisser la musique
OK
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]